[Music]
we are creating the world's largest
acrylic mural by a single artist
but i knew that i didn't want to have
just a mural had to be a project that
really dove deeper into the needs in the
community and what a perfect opportunity
to do it in these massive grand
elevators my name is armando minjares
and i'm the project director and curator
for horizontes
[Music]
i immigrated to the united states in
2001. i am an artist but i've also been
a community organizer working on mostly
immigrant rights
so the work that i do now really
combines my work as a community
organizer and
bringing that into creative expression
and kind of mix in those two horizontes
it's a large-scale community engagement
art project that's another one who was
painted as part of the project too
this is painted by heather and these are
all women from the north end and these
are all her
her tias and abuelita and you know her
the women from her family they grew up
in the neighborhood the project really
focuses on bringing solidarity between
the primarily latino neighborhood and
the historical african-american
neighborhoods with these murals one of
my personal goal is to have people of
color depicted in the most magnificent
way that we could
[Music]
the people that are depicted in the
mural are people they used to live in
the neighborhood or they currently live
in the neighborhood
and we went and dig through the
historical archives and pulled
photographs from the people that helped
build the tracks that we're surrounded
by those were mexican laborers that came
a hundred years ago
thanks to the internet i found gleo she
got painted some giant towers in brazil
so i knew that she had the skill and the
ability to paint large scale
and she flew down from colombia into
kansas
and she's been here working on the
project
my name is
[Music]
[Music]
what i hope that this means to the
community
is that we feel proud of where we come
from that we take ownership of our
neighborhoods of our communities and
continue to expand this work
all of us whole different identities
were people of color were immigrants
were queer people women here we are
painting the world's largest mural not
because they want to hold their record
but because these are stories that need
to be told and to remind ourselves that
we need to continue to work together
[Music]
you